hey everyone welcome to simply launch
youtube channel in this session we will
be learning about the match function in
excel or also called as index match
function in excel but before we begin
let me tell you guys that we have daily
updates on multiple technologies so if
you are a tech geek in a continuous hunt
for latest technological trends then
consider getting subscribed to our
youtube channel and don't forget to hit
that bell icon to never miss an update
from simply learn now without further
ado let's get started with our one point
agenda that is match function in excel
for that let's get started with
microsoft excel
so you can see that we have got started
with microsoft excel and on the left
hand side we have a simple table with
all the teams in an id industry starting
from i.t admin testing development to
client consultant support we have got
everything in this particular table
now our main idea is to find out the
index of these particular elements for
example if you wanted to find the index
of the element marketing then how could
you do it so here let's try to use the
match function in excel for that we want
lookup value and position so on the
right hand side you can see that i have
created two separate columns as lookup
value and positions so in the lookup
value column we will be inserting the
value of which you want to find the
index
now
for example let us consider that we want
to find the index value of team
marketing
so i'll be writing marketing in this
particular lookup value
now how to find the index value of the
element marketing for that we will be
using the match function in excel
now after writing the match function you
can see that it is asking for three
different parameters
so the first one is the lookup value
second is the lookup array and lastly we
have match type so lookup value is the
value of which you are trying to find
the index that is marketing this
particular cell so we have selected the
lookup value which is the first one next
we have to select the lookup array that
is from which set of elements you want
to find the index so the set of elements
are
this
i admin testing the column which we have
created the a column now we have
selected the lookup array and lastly
the match type is it you're looking for
less than or is it you're looking for
exact match or is it greater than match
so for now i want exact match so i will
be selecting the exact match that is
zero
now there you go you have the exact
index of the element that is five
now we have selected
all the ten teams starting from it one
admin two
testing three development for marketing
five so that's how you find the index of
a selected element in excel
now we just have like 10 elements so we
have got the uh
writing of the elements or you know uh
choosing the elements in a easy way but
what if if we had like 100 elements
right could be a little different
okay so let me put it simple
now you wanted to find the index value
of finance so right now we have
marketing and you wanted to type in
finance and
you missed out a letter a
okay
now you're not finding the right index
to avoid such problems you can always
take the help of
data validation in excel
that is using the list in data
validation in excel you can see a small
drop down icon here right you can choose
that and here you can see all the teams
that we have created in the left column
right so here i can scroll down and
choose the finance
and there you go i have the index value
okay again we need to copy paste the
same match function in excel over here
equals to match
lookup value
lookup array
and
exact match
so there you go that's how you make use
of data validation in excel and using
the list you can comprehend all the list
elements in this particular column into
the list of data validation and you can
choose the team whichever you want to
find the index for so this is how you
can make use of match function in excel
or
index match function in excel
now with that we have come to an end of
this tutorial on match function in excel
if you have any queries regarding any of
the topics covered in this session then
please feel free to let us know in the
comment section below and our team of
experts will be happy to resolve all
your queries until next time thank you
stay safe and keep learning
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click here